ينضم الينا من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي الطاهر اذا القتال مستمر
رغم المناشدات والمفاوضات كذلك اليوم كان
شهد اشتباكات قويه كيف يتطور الوضع الان
نعم رغم كل هذه المناشدات فان دائره الحرب
اليوم في الخرطوم قد اتسعت بشكل كبير يعني
هي الاوسع منذ ان انتهت الهدن التي كان قد
اعلن عنها بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع وكان الاشتباكات الاعنف التي
استخدمت فيها الاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
وكذلك الطيران الحربي السوداني في شمال
الخرطوم بحري في منطقه الكدر حيث قامت
قوات الدعم السليم بمهاجمه معسكر للجيش
السوداني في هذه المنطقه وقال الجيش
السوداني انه تصدى لهذه القوات قوات الدعم
السريعه التي قالت انها قد اسرت ايضا عدد
كبير من الجنود السودانيين في هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى ان هنالك ايضا هجوم لقوات
الدعم السريعه على منطقه او القائد الجويه
لوادي سيدنا في جنوب او في شمال ام درمان
في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى ان هنالك
اشتباكات في شرق النيل واشتباكات ايضا في
الخرطوم جنوب الخرطوم في جبره وصحافه
والمناطق المحيطه ايضا بالتواجد قوات
الدعم السريع في الكويت اذا نحن نتحدث عن
اتساع رقعه الاشتباكات اليوم رغم ان
المناشدات كانت لهذه الجهات
للجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السليم من خفض
التوتر ومحاوله تقليل او تنظيم القتال
بعيدا عن المناطق السكنيه التي يعني يتاثر
بها المدنيون بشكل كبير واضحا الهدنه التي
وقعت والاتفاق الذي وقع بين الطرفين في
جده لم يفعل بما فيه الكفايه لخفض هذا
التوتر وتنظيم هذا القتال خاصه وان هنالك
تصاعد في هذا القتال وليس هنالك ما يشير
الى تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق لربما لغياب
الرقابه او الاليه
لمثل هذا القرار هذه الحرب ايضا دائرتها
اتسعت هو شملت ايضا ولايه غرب دارفور في
الجنينه كانوا هنالك اشتباكات عنيفه هي
الاعنف خلال فتره الاخيره ما ادت الى مقتل
المئات وجرح الالاف خاصه وان والي ولايه
وحاكمي قيم دارفور يعني ناشر دوله تشاد
فتحه الحدود ومحاوله استقبال الجرحى
لمعالجتهم هناك باعتبار ان المرافق الصحيه
في هذه الولايه لا تستطيع ان تتعامل مع
هذا الظرف تحديدا والاتهامات متبادله بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وكذلك
من يقول ان هذه هي حربه قبليه ولكنها واضح
هي من تداعيات الحرب التي تدور هنا في
الخرطوم كذلك شملت هذه
الحرب ايضا منطقه
الرهد ومدينه
وان كانت على المستوى اقل ولكنها بدات
تتسع في تلك المناطق الاوضاع
وانتشار هذه الاشتباكات ادى ايضا لتفاقم
الاوضاع الانسانيه في الخرطوم وزياده
معاناه السكان من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
والمياه وكذلك
الارتفاع الاسعار وشحا السيوله والشح
الوقود بالاضافه الى ازمه ايضا فيما يختص
بالدواء اطهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم شكرا
جزيلا لك